francisco españa lleva dos meses en una
unidad de cuidados intensivos su equipo
médico ahora está probando un nuevo
tratamiento con el que sueña la mayoría
de los pacientes
ahora por ejemplo en este paseíto luego
a ver si nos realizan a tomar una aunque
si una sin tu cerveza en el mar ya con
eso tengo bastante según los médicos la
luz del sol y la fresca brisa marina
realmente ayuda a los pacientes en su
recuperación de los paseos curativos a
el paseo marítimo es una de las que nos
gusta más a todos los que nos guste es
que vemos más claramente que tiene unos
beneficios y estos beneficios ahora
estamos en proceso de cuantificar los
también
ya que madrid no es una ciudad costera
no existe un peligro de contagio en las
playas en eso la preocupación es en
barcelona sin embargo un tercio de todas
las infecciones se han diagnosticado en
la capital donde se implementarán nuevas
medidas a partir de este lunes
la agrupación de personas se fija en un
máximo de 10 personas convivientes tanto
en espacios públicos como en espacios
privados hasta ahora este límite sólo
afectaba a agrupaciones en espacios
públicos y se ha ampliado en el ámbito
de los espacios privados las grandes
ciudades se ven duramente afectadas
según las autoridades una de las causas
sería la falta de prevención por parte
de los ciudadanos cuando regresan a su
vida normal
los españoles temen que el regreso a la
escuela de más de 8 millones de
estudiantes acelere aún más la
propagación del virus y lleve a la
instauración de un nuevo confinamiento